slow dizzy Southwest suggest ain't gotta
shut the tail long cuz the iPhone I
gotta jet long if you wanna come let's
go ain't going nowhere special
I just want to see more disco hit your
number catch though
[Music]
heyyo that it is Thursday yes I mean I'm
sure some of you probably tune in to our
morning stream so we're doing afternoon
things now and Madden 20 for those of
you with VA access you get that early
early exclusive goodness from Madden 20
but for everybody else it's coming out
on the 30th that's right if you
pre-order you get it like three days
early or something like that which is
the 30th but a access members you got
the hook-up just download it right now
and you can get the 10 hour trial and
it's gonna be a good time it's the whole
game so you can see how it is how you
like it
what changes there are which there are
today because you know like most sports
games right you know unless you look at
like the first one from like 20 years
ago to now you're not gonna see as many
changes right changes are gonna be
important to go over by the way you guys
on Persia this David no I just kind of
assume you guys know that by now so I
forget to do it less but it's all kind
of a big deal you know
all right around these parts in the
GameSpot office up I just know you guys
like to get to the game you're like we
don't care of a team but yes EA access
we have some early access now to Matt in
20 right so I'm actually looking forward
to checking out I feel like every single
sports game not just mad and exclusive
but you know the graphics have been
getting really good it's all been
getting very realistic right almost to
the points where I watch like real game
someone was streaming like Super Bowl on
Twitch or something like right but they
had a controller in their hand they were
trying to pretend like it was the game
so that they wouldn't get shut down
and for at least like the first 10
seconds I was like wow the graphics so
good and I was like oh it's Madden no
wait it's actually like the actual
football game so you know if I could
just dive right in so I know you know
EAS got its fair share of people who
kind of expect the same things just
another numbered release right what's
the difference between Matt and 20 or
Matt and 13 there are some differences I
mean most of them end up being kind of
small you have your you know your revamp
menus you get your revamp graphics the
HUDs and things like that and just
generally better graphics as each year
goes there's actually some new gameplay
stuff that they're doing and we're gonna
try and see if we can kind of unlock
some of them and one of them is this
whole superstar x-factor thing I heard
about that and I mean I'm really
interested in this because basically
you've got these studs on every team who
have almost like these intrinsic perks
and they can do something that might
change the face of the game you've got
actually I'm not gonna talk about khalil
mad cuz I'm a Raider fan and we but
let's go to my Brown was good Steelers
fans don't ask me I gotta know in chat
who's your favorite football team yeah
yeah watch some footballs I got a no
yeah y'all should actually start giving
me teams to play as actually for when we
go to the head-to-head we'll see which
teams you guys want to see the Rose but
um we got intending Brown you see right
here so his run after the catch right so
he wins the run after the cash catches
against single coverage he's got four
additional hot routes in any wide
receiver position and he's got a quicker
grab and go he can turn and change off
the direction after the catch that's
cool you know that's not something I'm
gonna be able to pull off right now
after a year of not playing Madden 19
but this is something that for those of
you who are really into Madden I think
you can have a lot of fun with this you
can really kind of make these characters
your own right
you've got your defensive backs your
stuff like Von Miller he's got that edge
threat
you got Patrick mahomes the face of the
cover right and whoever said 49ers and
Chad I'm not playing as the 49ers I can
tell you there you go to the Raider
Nation all day I work at Cisco when I'm
a Raider boy let's go you know I'm a
toss to vote to the 49ers
we should do a battle of the day then
huh that'll be fun
but yeah so I mean what are you kind of
what have you noticed from the hype of
Madden 20 like in the trailers and stuff
like that I've heard a lot about this QB
one
sure yeah QB one right that's been yeah
that's been mostly like the bee thing
I've been hearing about this new mode
right right Emily kind of look forward
to that but at the same time in general
I feel like and you guys can correct me
if I'm wrong because I'm very new to
sports games except UK right except UK
yeah yeah I know like that I find it
interesting that each player kind of has
their own personal perks and their own
buffs and stuff like that so it's like
if you think about an RPG it's right
it's like oh I'm gonna have this visa
you know this armor and these boots
right but it's like each player is like
the armor and boots and gloves of your
whole team sure like I'm gonna make my
team really buff on the defense or I
want this person to you know well is it
running catch that you run after the cat
run after you catch I feel like these
are cool bus and like you know additions
to your team that adds the game aspect
right if it's like oh sports games
sports games EA we've seen them with all
the sports games but they are adding
gamer elements I feel like these are RPG
elements yeah sure so you got it you got
to give them credit there too I've in my
opinion and the thing is is that you
know it's a yeah it's always it's always
an updated roster but every summer man
really high profile players end up
changing teams and not spawn you know
it's fun to see and Tony Brown on the
Raiders right it's fun to see all these
players here you know just kind of just
does the team and you're feeling the the
climb of another NFL season right around
the corner that's one thing about sports
games too is that he's there in game
rosters up-to-date with what's actually
going on in the league
or in the Association or whatever the
case may be so it's it's a little bit of
a way to stay up to date right without
actually for sure for sure no it's it's
a good time and I think for those of you
who really are interested in the
mountain you're gonna have a lot to see
so let's dive in right now let's start a
game let's do it throw some balls yeah
yeah see and okay I know people will
talk about the minis but I love that
they ask you for your favorite team cuz
every time I log in you got the bump in
soundtrack and then I just see Derek
Carr right there this cocky pose and I
love it I love it
yeah your hashtag Raider Nation that's
that's tight you know for those of you
who are Eagles cheese fans it's gonna be
curated and that's cool it's like a
personalized experience yeah oh we got
here have the best soundtrack oh they
are like what's your favorite video game
soundtrack my go-to k-19 because like a
bunch of songs I listen to on the radio
oh no it's fun and if there's anyone in
chat who who's like a fantasy football
fan you know it's football seasons a
great time brought that up so person was
talking earlier about QB one right
that's a whole brand new mode and we
have gameplay of the QB 120 minutes of
the entire story mode going up if it's
not already up oh we got a head-to-head
match I think it's the Browns against
check it all out and it's gonna be tight
you know you can see kind of what the
deal is here but QB 1 you've got a
pretty much an NC double-a game right NC
double-a was it was a huge favorite a
lot of people liked NC double-a a games
and then they just stopped making them
and now in Madden they pretty much have
that in Tiger mode in the game
incorporated in it you make your own
superstar you go through and off you're
a Bama fan you can play as Bama
have nick saban kind of stare you down
and not let you talk to reporters it's
so good it's a good time Waipa the good
says quick question what's up do you get
all the stuff you pre-ordered if you got
superstar edition when the game
officially comes out if you preorder the
superstar edition well you're not gonna
get um access well actually no that's a
good point if you have EA access and you
appear to be superstar Edition like you
should be able to get everything yeah
yeah exactly but you can still only play
I think the first like no no you have
access to the game it's a whole week
early it's not like a separate entity
but if you don't have EA access and you
do pre-order it you're still gonna get
it three days early right so that's
gonna be the 30th so that's kind of how
it uh how it goes out so we got all
these featured games which is
interesting I think that's actually
based on the real life schedule but
we're gonna go custom so I got my
Raiders at home
ooh what do we do division rivals with
the the Chiefs or what stuff I know
Michael hi I'm in the office if he's
watching he's a Chargers fan probably
it's only showing three players so what
was that it's only showing three players
here yeah so those are the studs right
those are kind of like the main the main
people that you're gonna be looking for
so for example on the Browns you got obj
you've got Miles Garrett and it even
tells you if they're the superstar the
x-factor right that I rack em up the
unstoppable force and things like that
yeah a regular item I'm a little tilted
that I don't see Derek Carr up here and
they put LaMarcus Joyner but we'll see
let's go to battle the bay going let's
get the let's get the Niners up on here
I'm not from San Francisco but my mom is
is she so growing up you know in our
household we were 49ers fans yeah yeah
that's how you become a fan of something
absolutely you know 49ers fans my
grandma she would like slip me dollar
bills to go tell my mom that my favorite
team was a cow
okay we grew up in Texas right so um you
know she was this huge troll and it was
just really fun right I find it even
more funny than I've come full circle
and I'm like in San Francisco now so I'm
like oh I guess I can't cheer for this
team now for sure even though I'm not a
Golden State Warriors fan right I am a
Spurs fan go Spurs go wrong game it's
totally fine to k20 will be here so it's
a full disclosure we're gonna we're
gonna do this I'm gonna play one round
on our case so I can get kind of the
vibe for it again cause like I said in a
while and then then we can go into that
already someone who knows American
football
yeah it's hard to pick up and understand
bass in the UK so I'm gonna play NBA or
PES the Cavs are like American football
so I don't think so because it is a
video game you will intuitively be able
to pick it up and understand how to work
on offense
how to kind of like you know top of the
ball and they do have a training mode
it's like your biggest obstacles are
probably just gonna be the actual rules
of football like accessible to you but
that's lesson like a gamer thing and
more of like the action
pretty straightforward right we got a
field one team tries to run the ball
down switch it up my description of
football right now is probably not the
best but right and I mean it's gonna
help if you know certain rules no Jenna
Coleman come on my seller said basic
Simon she's sorry no actual no I think
you'll be okay
it'll help to kind of understand tempo
you know like how to run it's a minute
drill or something like that especially
if you're playing online Oh try to Juke
me no key one here says go Spurs might
be a little distracting here in the
commentators I got a drown them out yeah
number 10 but no one's there to receive
me forth and forth
[Laughter]
yeah just win baby Alex Rivera you got
it man you know it if you're oh yeah
that's a touchback
hey Alex Rivera if you're in the base
last year for the Coliseum man it's on
the time to get a ticket me give a
farewell before they move to Vegas
dude I lived in Vegas where a short six
months before I moved out here and I
kind of watch their progress on Ranger
Stadium because like a skeleton it looks
much smooth there but I just think it's
so cool how they're able to just say hey
we're bringing a new football team here
so we need a stadium right right right
you'll know for sure
[Music]
[Applause]
Marcellus look just down the nineteenth
of free so you're gonna try it yeah
enjoy a mess that's it's a good time you
know you're not gonna get no superstar
x-factors but you'll you'll get the
Madden experience you get to practice
that before I'm Adam absolutely Oh user
jus right so I'm letting some of these
questions cuz they're getting into the
minutiae of the game can you move the
teams to a new location and franchise so
we haven't played franchise mode yet our
reviewer Eddie who is in Australia but
is American is very good at these games
and he's gonna go into all of those
great details soon my guess is that yes
you will be able to because they keep
updating all these different things for
franchise mode for either q1 it sounds
like it should be
available you have to feel like he's
gonna have a pretty big game on the
ground I just ran the ball like 20 times
in a row you gotta get it come on car
passes away
[Applause]
Renfro hunter Renfro you pick all right
I like it
we got Sonia brown on the post right
over the middle oh I threw right in the
traffic oh we got an hook we got the
bench that's probably my favorite or
almost always a guarantee not all this
place around the outside oh he's good
he's good he's good yeah Oh get off me
[Applause]
yeah that roll tide are be all right you
see it we got some Bama fans in there
yeah they're too Brown there you got a
man out on the post
[Applause]
philanthropy touchdown endzone football
that's what we're about here
that's
full disclosure if that was online that
would have been picked off but it's all
good that could be a fun together
all scream towards the end couple weeks
down the line get some of the folks out
here - that's alright Tony Brown at the
end zone I see you I see you oh he's oh
oh I uh I let's call to celebrate mom he
got a team celebration you know I always
used to get super scared when they would
do celebrations because sometimes they
would do something like jump up in the
air and I just like you know crash into
each other what if you landed wrong yeah
well we go for two we go to our replay
the boring PA team's what we got I'm a
shady shady mypos what idea I'm gonna go
fits here it's Arcade Mode we can do
this it's all good
[Applause]
I smell okay so now I got it
there we go that's probably always been
the most anxiety inducing thing about
watching someone like at just like the 1
meter line right they still can be
touchdown you're like awesome New York
you want to see some NCAA game play we
have NC Double A game tied it's gonna go
up it's I think it's Texas Tech and one
other team but it's from the the qb1 NC
double-a no that was a bad cake but it's
all good what are you preparing for NFL
so I did the college that I went to we
didn't have a football team we had a
soccer some severe UCSB right and the
necessay yeah the other football but I
mean if I went to like ASU if I went to
bantha or Berkeley you know I would love
uh I'd love NC double-a there's a
passion for sheriffs and now I'm into
growing up in Texas but they football
very sees
thanks so much so that they were like
leading up our neighborhood right by
like the strict twist the line to split
people up was so crazy because they
would specifically want like this clear
to go to their high school yeah the line
wouldn't be like all right here's the
lien Street and then unless decide to go
to this house thing and the right thing
is going to that one it was like and
then I watched that show called like
Friday Night Lights so someone in the
comments asked I said that this is
probably on Pro and I'm very flattered
these Lemmy's that I'm killing it right
now but on it's not on Pro actually but
it's it's not on all matter neither it's
I'm all pro so I can kind of get warmed
up a bit it's on arcade the next round
we're gonna go we're gonna go all mad
and simply not an outlaw I promise you
it's not uneasy it's on all three medium
angel if you get EA access can you play
a man in 20 trial yes you get 10 hours
you have a 10 hour trial for the
entirety like where do you feel that
time online yeah online sick you start
flexing man start start talking some
smack get some people are rage quit
that's the Madden life and this is this
is honestly therapeutic for me because I
love working here and I usually do
destiny and fortnight and all these
more and it's like Michael hi him too
but he's busy working on a wolf he's
proving our point that sports games and
they only get so much left right
certified boat as an alignment I really
appreciate how they show the line bro
shouts out to you man I played a right
tackle starting right tackle on varsity
for years see a towline football I do
feel like okay like in real life are
more likely to be a lot of play like
people I know that please you can have
either played basketball in real life
like in high school or even so much so
as like they used to play they're really
good an injury and then too
ding tire was dirty
no it's dirty yeah he was heart was like
oh there was a question oh so can you
please answer if you buy someone on
might mad at Ultimate Team if you get to
pick their abilities they come with one
or more still early to say this
literally what you're seeing right now
this is the first time that I've booted
this game and I'm playing in and we just
went with head to head we're gonna get
some mad at Ultimate Team I'm looking
into doing some some guides for a madden
ultimate team some starter like packs
and things like that to see what you can
set up so just stay tuned and we'll
we'll answer everything and the
community matters good a close man
saving is
[Applause]
it gives you a boost already it's
alright do you actually don't live each
day so I'm closer to the radius than I
am to well next
[Applause]
how you gonna do me like you know next
season are they gonna change a mat in 20
to reflect well not when I'm a ton 20
but probably 21 yeah that's how it other
things all right I mean once the
official year like it's UK you can make
your own sneeze rain you could choose
like your own city and stuff like that
probably gonna do me like that couldn't
catch it I got I got distracted man I
got this jacket I'm just I'm waiting to
look at chat and waiting to see an
outlaw spawn she's probably gonna wipe
to the gods the clear stuff he's get all
the stuff from star Edition and EA
access I want to say I want to show ya I
really do because but I have been I'm
just doing the trials it's hard man okay
no until you because I'm not sure if
they would be able to actually tell who
purchased that surgeon he didn't like
already so I'm not sure getting some
chickens here I'm lying so much peace
more than like being in a
[Applause]
so uh patty was like a result yeah it
was like he was dance
they're not gonna show his feet he was
out no he was he was in there probably
laughing better I know they're like yo
dog I was actually out on that good
thing we paid that referee am I
nah man we're not the Patriots that's
like the most important yeah what do you
do when the amount of hours to play mat
and 20 is over free access so then
you're given a choice you're you're
pretty much told to to purchase again if
you want to keep playing the good thing
is is that any progress that you have
done is carries open you can just pick
up where you left off yeah
all right hunter Renfro as soon as you
got freaks suit you got on the rap you
fight to the final whistle anyway that
law says NFL 2k5 young for that I was
NFL Street I'm like the Gamecube and
honest that's not the first time I got a
no chat like what made 2k v the best one
because you only assumed overtime with
technology and everything else at this
they're only gonna get better but
there's always that like one game in the
franchise everywhere in in every game
that is just better than everything for
those of you play like you better catch
your train you better games right
there's been a ton of WVU games but
Smackdown it's probably the best in my
opinion I just find that to be a common
even though technology advances the game
itself is just like oh yeah we're
pushing us now we're just gonna Jimmy G
just wants to [ __ ] a man to his vest
Aaron gotcha some person
[Applause]
someone paying on Erte let him know that
his 93r coming back I just took my
pencil back just dough do some of the
chat is saying
2k5 was better because the AI who was
way better and it was better in that
game than in current magazines first
person's plan to pay by who I prove
whenever but it sounds like all sense
everybody to be nineteen on the switch
yeah Graham and I fell Street on
GameCube that's my stuff that's the
thing that got SSX tricky boy okay I
brought I've stirred up a lot of WWF and
thanks to my
now he's wide open oh my goodness
the Niners I started out so strong you
know I'm just like well asked me what's
my favorite sports games all three
progressions on that touchdown pass but
I do feel like either NBA Jam it's good
or NFL Street or probably a few of my
favorites worth beans and light not
because they were super realistic like
because we were walking you know no one
forgets when you're on fire
[Applause]
Ami's competition with football games
that would be nice to see you know it's
kind of like what fifa and PES right
she's got really passionate fans to run
the RPO I don't know what that means I
just write it off even your are mad in
the profession I don't unused
abbreviations explain to me what our
goal is let's guess
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
cuz he's a superstar as well on that
Lake his pass option okay yeah yeah so
the question was how do you run it like
how do you explain how to run the RP on
this game for sure
throw your your guess is as good as mine
because Bernie no cuz during the year
when everyone was doing the run option
with Kaepernick with Russell Wilson and
all these all these young TVs and the
league had yeah stop throwing a Sherman
that's every time dudes I yeah you're
right and he's shadowing ground which is
unfortunate so but uh
brpi usually you end up specifically
choosing a run option play and then
there's a specific key buying to
pitching the ball or keeping it when you
read the offensive line
[Applause]
Chrystia says you're very odd no no I'm
not I'm not a review yeah David here
handles our gameplay I kind of scream I
do some games sponsored screens - but
we're not reviewing it you know we have
an amazing team of her viewers right now
who maybe we can get to review - David
getting swatted right now against the
Niners I did this on purpose Tony we're
not either nation over here we got
people trying to add these distractions
I already have not in 20 can I delete
trial after I'm all right
dammit I'm no more no more passes over
person who has the best uniforms in the
NFL
I personally am wearing black and white
so the readers don't like you know I
can't like recall every single team
[Applause]
Chrissy says we're amazing non reviewers
thank you thank you sorry I'm getting
like I'm slowly gradually getting saucy
if anyone ever placed me on online
Madame this is you're making Raider
Nation look bad and it'll be available
to everybody else on this idea which is
very simple i running a screen
Arliss come on boys come on get that
block we're gonna be streaming some
Wolfenstein also tomorrow restraint we
stream some side mission stuff today
with David and John Luke which is
awesome but we're gonna show off some of
the main story tomorrow which is gonna
be really exciting we're also running it
on this really awesome
in this I laptops pin I have a laptop
the eye game on and it's about to kick
the bucket so this other laptop is is
very shiny and pretty in my eyes videos
my movements light shrouding oh did he
get it I was like that was really close
for the line again challenge everything
yeah I really should know I'm not gonna
answer so you know what is in full swing
yeah are you like one of those like
Sunday night football guys like every
Sunday like don't invite me to anything
NFL red zone like I said I play I play a
lot of fantasy football
[Applause]
we've been gradually increasing the
total pot that we head into the kitchen
support your weight how does fantasy
football work exactly like I get the
gist yeah there's definitely more to it
that I don't know just assure you
basically give me someone you know to be
good it can be someone that just like a
player like you go like around the
circle and everyone trash the win until
they fill up you can yeah come on that's
too long they caught it but ah yeah CBS
has a great full disclosure you're only
six you know Yahoo ESPN they all have
really really good really good team you
name however those players do right so
like let's see you know your quarterback
throws three touchdown passes so like
all of those that like accumulate among
13 so they're real like that go to your
team's all combined
has the best at so basically life you
don't think a lot to be practical so
basically you have yeah you like
touchdowns worth six points every ten
yards just one point PR gives it sounds
fun but I would not want to be the
person someone asks why is he a gating
on Julie that's my fault
I keep like you sipping the cutscenes
really tilted okay
your guy was sleeping hey right back at
you someone asked what was my was my
first football game it was NFL Street oh
I mean I told you the starting at my
back when I was younger and you know you
know when you're young and your parents
buy you all of your videos
why definitely is really old football
game we had just gotten this brand-new
total Club big screen this was before
big screens were thin it was a berry and
we were playing we didn't have a secret
so we left the console and when we went
back to watch regular TV the imprint of
the football field is burned into the TV
and me and my brother that's one of my
strongest memories when it comes to
flames come on like my cousin sorry
yeah yeah but when you claim in the game
the commentators are lights away
DeMarcus Cousins definitely the type of
player who has the skillset to come back
from an Achilles tear whatever you know
he's in the game and he's playing really
well he's got all sorts of time hey I
was just like hey referee catch 35 cover
16 right that's right oh snap in out
losses the Niners are greater than the
Raiders yeah
it's looking like your right now I live
for all of you good Peter
why Scott Shannon do you know what an
outlaw you and me we're playing on I
just take my rage out on all of you it
does exactly it's actually really Chris
and this isn't on PC exactly
oh my god me
David you forgot to roll out the red
carpet for him for that touchdown
he's almost nailed everything else but
you know what we should do you and I
should go head-to-head and play and play
next how about that all I do is go for
he'll let you know why don't we play a
1v1 and lo and we'll see we'll see Wow
oh we for sure have a Cardinal fan
someone's name is literally Larry fan so
yeah and I know what you're about
but hey Larry Fitzgerald man's respect
him one of the best to ever do it it
doesn't help that I'm running the same
place oh come on only runs so fast
there's no George kettle all right now
I'm just gonna run it non-stop the
plates there we're not getting picked
kale if it looks like it in constant
management on PC yeah for sure and I
played Mountain my team's whistling it
was it was nice
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I'm not passing it here not with
Sherman now with lockdown you're gonna
[Applause]
come on
gave it on the same squad here in the
office and and we're the gameplay
gameplay never here is going Gang Gang
Gang on thank you again yeah yeah yes or
Squatch yeah that's our squad quarter
the game game game game blame game let's
go Rams and says come on pairs you do it
for the bros Sosa says bro this Troy
have zero fear about football facepalm
emoji shake mine you gotta throw the
ball to your guys until you get to the
endzone there you go I know you know one
thing about football
let's go and you already had your you're
full disclosure you're Greg Watters is
it true you can get that you can't
yes three days early no you can if you
if you do the ten hours child can you
preorder the game you still get a three
days early if you have EA access and you
buy it it's yours
so these are all kind of just like perks
in addition to the fact that you trim
like a loyal and yeah access people I
think he got like 10% off or something
that's a good question so steady Merkin
says if i buy the one month access today
does he still get access to ten hours
like if he became a member today would
he still be able you know that's
probably why they've use it because they
want more people yeah they want people
together
so if you want to play some math then
sign up yeah just keep that
[Music]
now I do like football with personally
basketballs Marshall engaging and it's
more of the sport that I complete - you
know I haven't actually played a game of
football since I was like like and it
was in my street on my block it was like
two-hand touch it wasn't like we
actually tackle each other yeah yeah so
like basketball was a more accessible
sport ringing I think naturally I just
like truth even playing to cable I
watched Madden tournaments treaty hi
that's because like totally mad as
players and fellow they're also very
like they're not like I used to do some
TOS with court gave you all like the
Madden tournament official thing that
even the ones that are broadcasted on
Tuesday
and you know the players there the
players is leave by it by like a just
like that because they are official
these players in there and get it like
really crazy stuff so it's like even
though I might not be as in-depth with
this game the league itself or this dish
is really cool and I would recommend
anybody at home who is playing like mad
and competitively or they're really good
and stuff like that you should go check
it out these tournaments whose you know
there's sports games support their games
in ways that I haven't really seen from
other like 2k week and then Madden has a
lead also and you got the flag is that
against us oh yes the facemask can't be
smashed the Raiders even though we're
usually the ones we need the league in
penalties Oh
like his boy the school got the we yeah
let's go we won't we go for two yeah if
you wanna you wanna hit it you gotta hit
that fuel bill tie it up - it's my EA
access expires today do I still get to
keep my ten-hour free trial that is a
very very technical assumption would be
that if you start your 10 our trial book
or your 88 access expired yeah he'll
probably be able to keep it that's my
assumption but that's a very technical
question I would say just trying to
access it before it expires - he black
[Music]
alright outlines it's your boy Jimmy G
let's see what he's got chicken stones
chat oh yeah there you go alright here
we go
defense my David's weakest part of the
game cover forest when the number one
suggests all right Jimmy G what you got
you know would be cool is that if every
person who like I don't know if every
person you like you can upload a picture
of yourself and they will take you in
the crowd always been kind of a weak
factor in these in these games yeah you
know you ever see like 2k the crowd
they're always just like you know but uh
but that would be really nice I'd like
to see myself I'm like a big old you
know
like I think it's ball girls we may give
like their GoFundMe or their Kickstarter
something like one of those rewards was
don't draw like an avatar based on you
and put you in the background oh my
[Applause]
god 51-yard touchdown watch it in slow
mo for those who write you have one
minute and or the last place I'm not
gonna look at chat anymore I don't want
to see I don't want to see what they
know I don't want to see what they have
[Applause]
just run it just run it all the way
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm so no it's green it's green because
you can't lose your purse matches I
think we got like we got like 30 seconds
left did I have to do you have to yeah I
mean if he gets one more touchdown does
it matter if you went for well no it's
in case if he gets a field goal right I
protect myself against that great big
place
Oh Jalen Rashard he's gonna do come out
there we go money let's celebrate what
would be yours touchdown celebrations
and mine yes oh yeah so it's kind of
stupid but like well I tried doing a
special on celebration once in in high
school because like as an old lineman
you never ever get a chance but I fell
on a fumble in the end
it was my dress and I didn't know what
to do I wanted to do something so crazy
like instead I spiked it but because
it's high school football you're not a
lot of celebrating so we ended up
hitting penalty touch don't count it but
I got I was given a really bad warning
and they got the new 15 yards back in
the day when a second female halo 3 that
came out I'd been playing halo fever
really all three came out and I started
a little team and we had a scrim against
PMS we had a scrim against Pima and like
one of their guidelines with literally
no teabagging oh my gosh you better
intercept intercept just gave you but
yeah one of their rules in the scrim was
like no teabagging rain and I think one
of our players like they killed somebody
and then they just like crouched into
the corner to like reload they like quit
the game they ended the scrim and they
were like no that's a penalty broke one
of our rules then it was crazy
but that's what that reminding me Oh
like no celebrating Rangers
no being happy
yeah mr. ass doing his best DJ Khaled
assassination another one going for
another oh they still had timeouts that
was not that was actually very scary and
dangerous to look at those guys just
like crouching up here the line dude
we're good that was a little closer than
I thought it was gonna be
there you go Chuck yeah Mike Shanin I'm
sorry I'm sorry you gotta you gotta walk
it off Josh Jacobs boy I'm excited for
him great the Chad doesn't believe you
they're like you're playing on the
rookie there's no way no I'm sorry it
was it was all-pro but it was arcade
which is why you have like these crazy
long you know plays and stuff like that
but we could ground it a little bit if
you guys want to see me suffer that's
okay unless if you wanted man is lying
to my soul playing a rookie I swear well
on on Antonio Browns mom I swear this is
this is this was all-pro where where can
i where can I pull up the there's gotta
be something that that shows what it was
play it on proof is not really where to
god I just oh no that's not gonna
believe me
wait you can rewind the stream it was
there you literally see it you literally
see
No that's great yeah and outlaw GZ man I
trashed the right of the Niners a lot
but I you should try to play someone
online no I don't got some pretty good
yeah we do there's also some really good
people online too alright what uh this
soundtrack though every like folks like
sports key oh god we are now at 27
minutes all right let's go
27 minutes so let's uh why don't we roll
a long shot mode says pack Jack let me
take forever long cuz that's got
cutscenes and and actually sorry I don't
think it is long shot mode pack Jack I
think it's it's this is face of the
franchise its qb1 rename yeah so it's
kind of like someone the long shot
except I think they're changing a little
bit to be less about an underdog and
more about you know that Cam Newton that
Superman in your face always their face
of a franchise right Holmes actually but
we do have footage of back alright let's
um I saw someone earlier in chat
requests a battle of el egg so that
would be the Chargers against the Rams
more than one are a city that has more
than one team I'm not a fan of it I
think I think the Chargers belong in San
Diego I think anyone who is a Chargers
fan will agree but they belong in San
Diego I think Rams going to LA is fine
because they used to being in LA Raiders
used to be in LA - but for all you San
Diego fans out there you know
but hey you guys have a Super Bowl
contending team to be honest this could
be your year
if Melvin Gordon says back in the day it
was such an abstract concept that a team
would move cities and like go somewhere
outside it was like this team belong to
this city and like that's it right now
like recent years teams are moving all
over the place sure sure yeah oh and
they're both evenly matched 85 85 we got
OC all-pro told you it was on there you
go
roof we'll try and see well Jenny Saul
madam won't get you guys in there but
yeah like I heard Kawhi Leonard was
getting denied at coffee shops because
he didn't go with the Lakers it said I'm
like in my mind like it's still away but
I guess the certain people in LA it's
not yeah it's not the lake show right
play against the Patriots tough guy yeah
all right let me play against the ranked
97 team because Madden can't get off of
Tom it's almost went to see me that
would be crazy
they're like big David Garcia we are
playing as the Rams so it is your lucky
day
but I had a short in the clock a little
bit so it's a three minute quarter if
you guys are just so she should stay
with there's a lot of time Madden's kind
Jason said bad idea I'm adding a note on
it see it's not but you can't you can't
win with Jack Handey she's in their life
Oh rookie modes good I can't play
nothing was more fun here on the harder
mode alright ready you guys ready for a
pick on the first play oh I'm ready
come on golf the to go disciplines all
of our viewers oh he's gone oh if that
was all-pro he would have caught that
but all Madden gets a little more
realistic
he's in the eye of the beholder
[Applause]
Lord said I'm going for the win
they're like hyping up this they're
adding more personality to the team yep
which by the way for any shell fans
actually I can't say anything yet but
there's personality and you guys can
find out real soon what do you got in
store for her Chuck come on man
briea now thank you remember waterboy
talking to each other on the field and
like talking trash how much leeway do
you really have to do that on the field
or is that just movie magic you're like
talking to someone like on the other
side absolutely so here's the thing if
you if you're on a good scene right you
can kind of take some liberties with it
and we were really good to believe that
we were in stand on the O line you have
different calls you know calls to say
who you're blocking someone's line up in
the shape technique or one or two you
know you say okay King Jackson those
were our calls right so it would be like
I want a double-team or I want I got
this guy with myself or I'm gonna push
them out that surely draw and so on and
so forth and it got to the point where
we would start making up like you know
we would make up random random calls and
stuff and actually my favorite was we
would learn the names of the defensive
line two days before we played and we
would start saying their names like so I
would call out the guys and I'd be like
Hausman Houseman and he'd be like cool
and then you know our QB would snap and
we've just you know pile-driving
but the utter you know Oh mind you can
get a little cocky if you're winning
you're losing the blame falls on you
right
but um one of the favorite things that I
had with me and my boy Dylan Shay
was we would start talking the defense
or actual way we would literally lineup
ecology yeah
and I would literally line up in front
of the guy I'd be like alright boy who's
just gonna happen I'm gonna line up on
you I'm gonna take you 101 Dylan's gonna
come over on a deuce and Shea it out for
the linebacker and the guy be like what
the hell we would do it we would and it
would work so much fun you know football
is a good time it was also hell's but it
was good yeah in sixth grade I you know
we were all sitting and asking questions
and I was like oh so you know what were
the requirements the girl wanted to try
out and the coach was like let's save
all the hard questions for later and
then you I didn't even answer me I mean
in hindsight I'm glad I did it because
you know and I probably got an injured
right
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
someone's disappointing with the blue
giraffe excited from how hard they work
out that they have these very nice
responsive deadlifts all that damn madam
Jamis uh was good man yuri eva joined us
on the tail ends of our stream but we're
glad to have you you can watch me get
body lines all mad in your simulation
mode so the thing about the simulation
mode is it actually represents the
madden ratings so if a player has a low
speed rating or a low acceleration
rating the game doesn't automatically
adjust it'll annoying thing that people
that the ref was like Miss or not
there's like so many layers
there was a lot usually you know it's
it's whenever the refs not looking you
kind of do what we call extracurricular
activities where and the dock while
someone might kind of give you a little
mean they'll get a little rough right
where no one can see you know I can tell
you right now this one's an L Jack go
ahead no it's okay you can just you just
spam F for me at least you sad that I'm
getting deceased right now I don't just
be like if you support yeah there you go
we got enough they're giving you ass
and maybe you'd be better at horn I'm
not true I see I can tell you that right
now I just suck it for night and I'm the
main port I got here oh let's go barely
come on are there any surprise mechanics
well yeah we saw it we saw a couple
right the surprise mechanic that we
noticed was I through a height of oh I
hear a tight pass to Antonio Brown and
who was lined up against Richard Sherman
and Richard Sherman has what we call
superstar attributes where he can he's
kind of like a ball hawk right so he can
just jump that route and really you know
punish the the QB for growing that and
he did I I threw a pic and as he maybe
pegs so but yeah so as there are certain
characters who have special traits
[Applause]
two-minute drill we see what's going on
got ten seconds you know I have always
liked the Rams helmet because it has
like yeah
sir this is really nice tonight a mascot
see sucker she's a fair way simulation
sucks I'm placing light let's stick to
arcade it's you know that's where the
real fun is is there a bug rumbling
honor Mark Sanchez retiring oh why you
got a doom like that no there isn't but
rusty piece first touch between this
game we can choose a direction as it
sees the cash in which direction he
wants to go really good question I think
you can finish that oh did I just jump
[Applause]
but you can you can adjust the way you
pass to help them give you direction you
can do it behind them by holding the
board for mud sing mad and acting like
okay now when we were playing on arcade
mode it was acting like 2k anyone from
GameSpot's watching we can let Michael
hime know that the charges are
[Applause]
[Applause]
gonna play some Madden with me later in
the week see game you know if I gets a
little bit of time to like sit down and
learn the road I'll definitely challenge
you don't worry two K's around the
corner different it's like if you get
good enough cards the gameplay Duncan's
really good in that game Tim Duncan
mister mister boring mister fundamental
mister fundamental thank you the
backboard legend I shut a fat tier for
it when I heard that he's gonna be the
assistant coach for Popovich right
I heard the bell are you gonna start any
no you know what let me save you this is
no boiler not knob under simulate
perfected and for what it's worth if you
play it don't play on some clown Kong if
you want a challenge car yeah would you
would rather play this or against
someone online that's a good point I
think I would have rather taken it
online actually you were right I should
have listened to you that's that's all
me and I'm paying the price these guys
pressing don't want to give me any yards
yo it almost ricocheted into his hand it
was almost a double spawn bolster
doubles bumbles look at they didn't look
at how they massacred my boy destroying
you but didn't they injured you on top
of that either way he threw him down I'm
sorry but that was straight disrespect
that looked like something my big
brother do to me like when we were young
and he's annoyed am i annoying I see
like nah I got I got it so I got it so
chat that all right don't forget for
those of you who came earlier you saw me
win the first girl so it's okay I won
during most of this stream c'mon cooks
that was an injured guy yeah I brought
him back he had back spasms oh no he
that's I don't know but I'm out defense
game over there doing victory formations
[Music]
controller is down the phone and
ultimate rage quit again alright well
whoever is the Chargers fan in there I
hope you're happy
battle live a Lay's was lost the battle
- babe you're won but technically not a
winner either you're even this is school
I would have failed we don't have quite
enough time to play another game but go
through a couple of you know futures
yeah before we close out the stream yeah
so for those of you who were here
earlier you might be familiar for those
of you who are new you've got all these
revamp mounts you have exhibition which
includes that head-to-head we just
played you play online
you've got the Pro Bowl - NFC vs. AFC's
best so you can have you know Tom Brady
chucking the ball to Travis Kelce right
it's like your own fantasy football team
got your skills trainer so you can be
better which is something I should
probably work on you know what I'll be
your skills trainer yeah there you go
now nothing to stop me so we got the
ultimate team right for those of you
familiar with Ultimate Team you
basically it's kind of like a fantasy
football team except you get cards and
set it up but it's a great way to sort
of make your own team pit it up against
other people online and see who comes
out to be the best of the best franchise
mode a classic favorite create our take
over a team lead into the Super Bowl
create a dynasty profit
and he got qb1 face of the franchise boy
mahomes throwing the ball like a
baseball my home my homes my homies yeah
Brandon cooks my homies eat um so we got
QB one which is the new longshot mode
for those of you familiar with it it's
great you get to basically take control
of a rookie QB or a pretty young QB and
leave the team or you can start on NC
double-a stuff you get drafted and you
end up leaving the face of the franchise
right and then you've got a lot of cool
things like superstar X Factor's the
de-facto brand new thing that Madden 19
arm out of 20 has that separates it from
that of 19 yeah Khalil Mack Aaron Donald
Bobby Wagner DeAndre Hopkins with best
of the best you can kind of go and see
what each of these guys have they have
like these intrinsic part perks which
person you mentioned yes like you know
can consider your team your body and
then all of your players like your vest
and your gloves and your boots and your
helmet and each person has their own
buses those absolutely I don't think
that's pretty darn cool and these are
some really cool perks and looking at
this if you're mahomes your throwing
distance increased by 15 plus yards so
that's no joke man yeah throw a Hail
Mary you got it right yeah talk early
you get a high fake-out rate on your
next Juke spinner hurdle
oh wait go up again more powerful
stiff-arm anomie there you go yeah
armbar right right you just lock him out
so that's it
obj rest in peace everyone who's a
Giants fan I'm sorry this is not here
obj it's got you know the faster Juke
animations grab-and-go rack them up
Kelsey my boy he's gonna be on my
fantasy this year for sure this is it's
really cool I'm actually really looking
forward to use x-factors and I'll try to
make like a I'll make a nice compilation
of these and put them up on gameplay
channels sometime soon this week
so you guys make sure you check that out
Matt and 20 will be available on the
30th but if you have EA access you can
play an owl for up to 10 hours and I
believe you also get a little bit of
like a few days early as well yes three
days early early so make sure you check
it out it's the next installment in the
series a series that I kind of feel like
we've all grown up with at this point
right right
definitely check it out sports games
totally and you know for those of you
real quickly if you're not excited about
Madden well I'm glad you're able to
still join us so you could make that
decision for yourself and you can always
know that in the future tune in to
GameSpot and you can see do I like this
game why not my interesting we got the
hook up everything for you straight up
good it's Church it's not true it's
church every weekday 11 a.m. guys there
you go that's Harry gamespot have got
you guys covered we have two streams
today we had two streams yesterday but
usually we have at least one streams per
weekday so please come on back and hang
out with us and play all the newest
games and have fun and just you know
hang out because that's pretty much what
we're doing we've been enjoying playing
so I'm adding with you guys today and
come back tomorrow we're gonna be
playing some Mario Wolfenstein yes yeah
so thanks for joining in have a great
Thursday and we'll see you guys